one of our missions in season two is to
go a little deeper
and explore some very real issues and
feelings that i believe
i don't want to assume
that we all share
um and when someone that you love hurts
you it's easy to hold on to anger and
resentment
and forgiving someone
you know it's not always the easy choice
it can be complicated
funny enough according to the mayo
clinic
it's actually much healthier to let go
of a grudge and move forward and
forgiveness can be very powerful
and
i have to tell you
the term forgiveness has been such
a huge theme
in my life especially
the last few years
and i received a letter from a young
woman in east berlin pennsylvania who
wanted advice on how to forgive her
mother so they could mend their
relationship
rachel grimm says her mother stepped out
of her life at a time when she needed
her most and
rachel is here to tell her story and so
i want to welcome her rachel grimm
everybody
i played so fabulous really you're so
fabulous oh my goodness i love you came
dressed up in your hot pink suit okay i
think we could sit here and compliment
each other all day i like it um okay i
was very excited to talk to you and your
story really spoke to me and will you
tell me and everybody about the letter
you sent yes let me read you my letter
drew i'm writing to you to ask for your
help repairing my bond with my mother
after she moved out and left my dad
brother and i nearly 10 years ago
the situation took away my confidence
brought on resentment and forced me to
balance being a freshman in college
while worrying about what was going on
back home
you're such a confident change-making
daughter and mother so i believe you're
the best person to get through to me and
my mom
thank you and i mean that
i am so honored yeah that you think that
and
you know
getting down to business i this is the
subject that is my karmic journey in
life yeah what happened to your mom and
what was your relationship growing up so
growing up we were super close because
she instilled such a confidence in me to
be confident in the woman that i was and
to go after anything i dreamed
just pushing me to be my absolute best
in everything i did so that's like where
we were
before
everything so what do you think led to
that
estrangement and will you tell us about
how that occurred
2008 the recession hit the united states
and a lot of families suffered a lot of
loss and loss that was ongoing and so my
family was a part of that we lost our
home our cars and in that
lost the relationship with my mom i mean
in addition to that loss then my brother
was diagnosed with type 1 juvenile
diabetes so my parents were under a lot
of stress financially relationally and
ultimately it led to
their demise and i mean it was
a long time coming but
when i was going into college kind of
everything hit the fan it all culminated
into
officially you know losing everything
and my mom
truly packing up a u-haul and leaving
and not us not being aware
what her life was going to look like
from there and
us not being a part of it and you're 18
yes you're going to college yes in
college and a u-haul is packed up yes
and
she leaves yes how did your life change
after that i mean that caused a lot of
a lot of resentment honestly um and it
took away that confidence that she had
built in me um you know figured out
things with my family to be with my dad
and my brother i worked full time to
like provide for our family and also to
be able to go to college so it was a lot
but we're here
did you talk to your mom during this
time
she would check in sporadically
but primarily i had the opportunity to
study abroad when i was in college i
worked really hard at that full-time job
and made it happen to study abroad and
while i was there she
would reach out via email which was
really powerful i think and to me showed
showed that she cared you know because
in that time i felt like she didn't
and
so she reached out to me and she would
just send me little correspondence
correspondences of like what's going on
back at home right not our home but in
the states and checking in on me
with my internship and my school and
everything i had going on there we never
in that time necessarily touched on
things with my family
and i don't know if that's because it
was email wise i think honestly there
had been such a loss of a relationship
in that time i think that was her way of
slowly trying to come back in and maybe
rebuild it and it being surface level
was easier than her digging deep into
those like really hard moments
what are you hoping
the outcome might be
like
today and moving forward absolutely well
it doesn't have to be exactly what it
was back then because
i'm an adult now you know and just being
able to build that confidence in our
relationship and not just be mother and
daughter but be mother daughter friend
too woman to woman too you know yes
exactly i think the word friend doesn't
fit in a mother-daughter relationship
personally yeah i always tell my
daughters i am not your friend yeah i am
your mother
and my mother acted very much like a
friend and that was our relationship and
it did not work
[Music]